yeah
that's so cool you film your elements
for real and you do your trick with real
footage because then it looks real in a
really compelling way
did you see it
did you see it no oh wait I see it
thanks to Betsy for sponsoring this
video hi guys happy Saturday I'm Jordan
and I'm here to talk to you about our
sponsor today Bessie so today in
particular I'm here to tell you about
their new shoe the storm burst it's
their dedicated hiking boot they have
all the same features of the other
bestie shoes they have the dimetex
material it keeps your feet warm in the
winter and cool in the summer months
they're also 100 waterproof and 100
vegan they even added an extra rubber
outsole so that you have extra grip in
those slippery wet conditions I
personally love Bessie's because the
weather is very unpredictable but I'd
love to be outside I love to go hiking I
love to go biking I'm learning how to
one wheel whatever it is messy shoes are
perfect and how they have a dedicated
hiking Booth so now I don't have to
worry about hiking in L.A so if you want
to add the new storm burst shoe to your
Gussy collection go to vesti.com quarter
crew and use promo code quarter crew for
15 off of your next busy purchase I knew
you guys are missing Sam Nico and ren by
now so bye I'll see you later enjoy the
rest of the episode said what's up
everybody welcome back to a chill
episode of the fxrs react that's right
it's middle of the day Wednesday just me
ran and Sam chilling on the couch no
Oscar nominees just a couple of us boys
I'm gonna look at some cool Clips my
Clips are gonna wake you right up I
promise I think I have clips that
neither of you guys have seen that are
actually really cool well I got a clip
that I don't think you've seen thanks to
the comments of last week's video and I
got a clip that you've heard of but
probably haven't watched
all right let's jump in
hey nice shot kid that was getting close
even for me Star Wars X-Wing is Star
Wars fan film sick have you seen this
Ren no have you seen the Sam camera I
gotta hit the sign oh
that's a lot of x-wings oh god oh I
thought those were
those were Star Destroyers
chips those faces are interesting is
there like a deep fake pass on that wow
turns out your years of watching VFX
every week have paid off but there's a
visor over the face so it's like there's
some heavy compositing going on in all
this this is insane yeah for a fanful
this is insane I think they called us
they called us a Warner yeah that's
right this is a water the camera hasn't
cut yet keeping track of the camera
placement and like the scale of your
city and making sure there's always
something visible is yeah not to mention
like pacing you have to pace your story
without the use of cuts like everything
just has to happen at cinematics
what
so sweet the world's biggest Boron oil
fracture
all the dirt man there's so much
simulation going on there's engine
lights through the smoke the transition
of scale is cool here where it's
something feels big and then it feels
bigger
it's so cool wait so the debris doesn't
go with the ship no the debris doesn't
have engines on it well but it's like
okay actually you're right it totally
makes no sense but in Star Wars it's all
made up
I mean if they were actually going that
fast how many broken necks would be on
board
Hyper Speed and then everyone
that's a really good Star Wars super cut
there each time they go to warp speed
everyone's heads
are showing a full retreat
yeah this is a fan animation kind of
inspired on the old X-Wing game by I
guess the channel Noble engine they only
have this in the behind the scenes on
their channel so it's like I feel weird
calling it a channel the group The
Artist the uh yeah how big is the team
that produced this I think it's
basically just one guy I could be wrong
we got another estaris on our hands here
maybe this could be like a two guy
situation I don't know I don't know
something about this I mean there's
obviously other people
the Big Challenge I see here is handling
scale you know there are levels of
detail like how many polygons are on
these building models and if so how many
of the high poly buildings do we need
close to the camera versus the ones that
are far in the distance because like yes
computers are great but ultimately you
know there are still like bottlenecks
Unreal Engine 5 is like the only other
exception to that at the moment with the
whole like nanite rendering you know
people often assume that with something
that is fully CG it's like you hit a
button and what we're seeing in the
final thing is like what got spat out of
the render engine but a lot of the time
that's not true at all and it makes me
wonder with something like this if maybe
they actually did a few different passes
of like here's the far background here's
the near background and here's another
layer of just like the ships and then
that all gets combined in compositing
well let's take a look at the behind the
scenes oh yeah so here we can clearly
see there's levels of detail that we're
seeing as well so it's like as they're
going down to the Earth all the
buildings are literally just like boxes
yeah they're blocking out everything
here which is a way to do it make get
all lightweight enough but you still get
the idea of what the final thing is
going to be then you replace each of
those little blocks with higher detailed
buildings and ships I mean the fact that
we're seeing this like cool shot with
this whole like executor rising out of
the surface and this is interesting
because it's not the craziest Houdini
Sim either it's just like the direction
the pacing the storytelling around it
makes it feel epic you're just breaking
up a box like this is just your basic
boronai fracture and then like rigid
body Sim but Houdini is able to like
intelligently attach all those pieces
together and have them break at certain
levels of stress as opposed to
everything just crumpling uniformly also
handling that many physics objects too
which is a white thing a lot of physics
plugins they just aren't built to make
this many fractures well this reminds me
of that one what is it that Rebel way
shot have you seen that one of the Star
Destroyer coming out of the ice oh yeah
yeah you've seen that one that one oh my
gosh that one is so cool
isn't that the light through the ice
look at how spicy that stem is I think
they probably saw that and they're like
we gotta do that yeah rubbleway is the
name of that awesome Houdini education
yeah so Jordan's watching this stuff
it's definitely one of those buckle up
okay wash your hands buckle up and like
yeah your computer for five days but
when you come out of the other side
you're like you can do it I mean the
only thing that's really janky in this
is the faces and even then they're like
they're not that janky they're like
they're interesting because they're not
janky video game faces they're less
[__] than I would have expected from a
CG face which is why I was like it looks
like there's like a deep fake past just
applied on top of the CG faces that's
actually exactly what they're doing so
yeah here's the original CG faces they
look like video game cinematic faces
shooting
Computing face look make face Banner
which is a great solution to like
bumping up the quality of your work
without having to like hire you know 20
people to do it for you yeah because I
mean it allows you to basically have a
bass Face animation that's still like
driving it but you don't need to have
the best like shaders and quality yeah
so at the end of the day you know motion
really drives it at the end of the day
you know what I personally feel like I
would have preferred to see the CG faces
but that's just me some of the shots of
tea fake faces worked great but I think
it's just a matter of like they're
mastering so many disciplines here so
like to also be able to just a steep
faking in one pass like it's a lot of
stuff to learn obviously this is
incredibly inspiring to see like a small
team be able to pull off something this
impressive but I think it's important to
note that it's like it's not just some
amateur in a bedroom making this which
is I feel what most people think of when
they hear the term fan film yeah these
are just like Professionals in their
bedrooms these guys know exactly what
they're doing in their bedroom
[Laughter]
look at that nice house look at that
water hitting the lens I've seen this
[Music]
close the door
there's a
okay I see what's going on it's a glitch
it's an EA game
this is funny because we can all relate
to video games glitching on US ah hello
fellow Gamers this is really well done
though it is it's extremely well yeah
it's like there's an art to making stuff
glitch in a I don't I don't realistic
way is that the right way of saying it
yeah nothing is realistic about a glitch
authentic yeah and authentic I like the
camera move at the end or like bobbles
back to the corner of the wall
thank you
this is so intense there's so much going
on unless you want to bet that's just a
CG person how much you want about this
that's a real person you think so yeah
they walked through that desk flawlessly
though I will say that the desk came up
to just below the bottom of her shirt
making an easy compositing line
wait did it just Loop is this my
favorite ad now what does it even like
don't live with lag is this an internet
provider
Horizon it's like a lot of effort for a
Verizon commercial it's a really cool
video I think you can make an argument
that 5G might not be the best
like you know like ISP situation for you
if you're you know you're a real gamer
but uh
you know as a real gamer uh
what I can definitely tell is that the
people who worked on this are very
experienced with these types they're
very experienced Gamers
like the polygons being triangles in the
floor like that's a very specific
aesthetic and you pointed out that
camera that has like that weird sort of
bezier Animation glitch on it right here
we're talking glitches to the animation
the camera
hahaha
which that's a glitch that only people
who animate will understand right so
it's like them putting in like all kinds
of little hints there's probably so many
Easter eggs in this I gotta wonder how
do you think they did the girl on the
bike it's like if a lot of stuff like if
you go through this so that's probably
just a picture of a van that's actually
there and they erase it and they just
you know scoot it around for some shots
or have a 3D model of the van and the
tree when it pops into the van is
probably a 3D model but this like sure
it's a 3D model bike but that's a great
shot of a person next to it not on a
bike I think this person was actually
riding a bike and they painted out the
bike and the legs and just rebuilt the
legs from scratch because I think the
jean jacket and the arms and the hair
the helmet face like that's all super
realistic but legs jeans shoes that sort
of thing is pretty easy to do and make
look photorealistic yeah you're right
because also I'm also seeing like this
little bike wobble right about here you
see the little wobble yeah it's like the
hands grab the handlebar it's something
that is gonna be pretty hard to
replicate if it's not a real bike yeah
and even like the pressure on the feet
as they pedal and stuff even if the legs
are replaced like it's perfect motion
right you only get perfect motion like
this with somebody actually on a bike
yeah wind in the hair the balance and
the shifting everything is so well done
it's very cleanly shot the VFX are super
super crisp and clean like nothing in it
you look at and go oh that's like a CG
thing like maybe that catch or but
that's like part of the joke yeah but
like everything about it it doesn't look
CG even though it's like so obviously CG
like even the clouds in the sky you know
you see that wait I didn't the clouds of
CG yeah it's just one Cloud picture that
they're just duplicating you're right
it's a cloud Sprite that's a Mario
reference in the background there that's
a cloud from Mario seriously straight up
it's the shape of the cloud from Mario
yeah like this oh my God this is what
I'm saying like it's so clean the
velocity they're applying to this is
like the same philosophy that like we
applied to all our early VFX videos and
like same with like the Freddy W videos
which is you film your elements for real
and you do your trick with real footage
because then it looks real in a really
compelling way whereas if you get heavy
into like putting CG into your scene
just try to cell CG is real is like a
huge task in and of itself and you miss
out on like the fun concept stuff yeah
like there for instance that dude it's a
real Buster filming on and he's a real
person there but the jean jacket comes
to his wrist and his hand is CG so they
can change the shape and position of
that hand as it grips different things
that pop in and out of existence
corporate [__] aside it's a really
cool video Yeah
I think that's the summary the creative
team killed it with this project I think
that is something we can agree on I just
like seeing like the high quality
version of shots that we've done so many
times over the years I'm like yeah they
did they nailed it yeah it's cool seeing
like the aesthetic like video game
glitches in real life like we've made
multiple videos with that as like a
theme for what we do yeah I think like
we to the glitch video obviously yeah
glitch but also the uh The Matrix yeah I
was about to say uh Early Access Matrix
The Early Access Matrix Video is like
the same thing I'll bet some people on
this team watch Corridor videos not
saying that they took our ideas or
anything like that no no no no we don't
own video game glitches as a concept no
not at all we live to inspire
James or Jim sorry I don't know which
one you prefer uh consider subscribing
thank you statistically speaking that's
your name
[Music]
So speaking of glitches and stuff this
movie we keep it this is an evergreen as
we call it it just keeps coming back
we're looking at the Polar Express so
check this out this is a serious glitch
or a non-funny wait can I you'll see
you'll see pay close attention to the
elves
Asians oh
did you see it
did you see it no
are you still there
no let's see let's see it go back oh
damn it's like where's balls
whoops I made it in
that's it
somebody else
there's too many elves that's what they
were saying too when they're working on
this
guys there's too many elves it was like
just do the shot dude hold on okay so
look below the p in Polar Express all
right look directly see the P now look
down from that P right about
now oh wait I see it
oh man
one of the elves to ride Heelys around
for the day what we're seeing is an army
of elves just marching along with a
bunch of different animations but one of
them doesn't have any animation on the
elf at all it's just in a walking pose
and it's animated along a spline
probably just going along so it's first
off just kind of funny to watch but I
think it's also something that is all
too easy to have happen
you have all of these different 3D
models of these elves they all have what
are called Bones in them that you can
animate to have them do different
animations and some of them are lined up
like those two guys there in front are
perfectly in sync with each other and so
if you just have one animation for all
the elves it's gonna look too uniform so
the challenge becomes like adding a
bunch of different types of animations
and scattering it across there so when
you're doing huge crowds basically
you're doing scripts because you're not
going to actually assign a unique
animation to each person by hand there's
just too many elves
there's too many else so many else well
let me sorry you can but if you're going
to make a bunch of characters like this
in Mass it's not necessarily going to be
a all right let's pick the animation for
each guy here there's a possibility that
when you're signing the animations one
doesn't get an animation either
something glitches out and it assigns
like a null animation and nothing
happens or what is couldn't even funnier
is if maybe they previous the shot or
had like an initial file set up that had
like sliding elves and then they took
that project file duplicated it deleted
all the previous elves except
accidentally left one in I I doubt
that's what happened
yeah what I think what I think happened
is that that elf originally did have an
animation but when it got sent to the
render Farm the link to that animation
got broken because that happens a lot of
the time when you're dealing with like
networked assets sometimes just like the
file path just gets corrupted somehow
the program doesn't know that it's just
looking at an empty folder and it's like
oh there I guess there's no animation
here but you don't know that until after
you get the render back because it looks
just fine on your computer but it's
rendering it on a farm on a bunch of
different computers and you getting it
back and that happens more frequently
than people really sort of explain I
want to find more glitches in this movie
is this if any movie to find glitches in
this is the ultimate one the Ultimate
Prize of funny glitches because it
already feels like on the brink of
glitchiness the movie itself feels like
one big glitch
no I don't mean to talk crap about the
Polar Express I mean yeah we've looked
at it before it was a very ambitious
movie it had limitations from the
technology and whatnot we're not hating
on the movie it's just it's delightful
to see that even your gods have flaws
that's what it comes down to it's like
there's how much can you poorly point
out and laugh when you have a bunch of
like incredibly high level experts doing
something it's like yeah not to mention
like what we're missing in the shot is
something that is a really artistic
composite that's actually happening that
we're totally ignoring right now watch
the characters and how they they
transition throughout the scene we go
there and the cabin illuminates more and
everyone gets blurry yeah and then
someone bathe into these 2D cutouts and
then they just kind of go it becomes
like an illustration from the book
exactly like wow that's actually really
cool it's also really clever because it
simplifies the amount of work that has
to be done so now they don't have to
render the inside of the train cabin for
the entire length of the cabin when
we're really just looking at a bunch of
loves doing flippy floppies for some
reason I feel like that's a frame that
was directly inspired from the book too
I know I think you're right this was
actually pointed out as a suggestion for
us to look at in the comments and I now
want to see what other funny glitches
are in this movie The Polar Express so
leave a comment Down Below on this video
If you ever find any more so I told you
guys it was a chill session of vfxrs
react no we're not looking at Giant
movies with billion dollar budgets we're
looking at the exact opposite
[Applause]